hoy vamos a dar una introducción rápida
a las mutaciones genéticas pero primero
repasemos el dogma central de la
biología molecular que es la idea de que
la información genética en una célula se
almacena en forma de adn este adn se usa
para generar a rn complementario a
través de un proceso llamado
transcripción y posteriormente este
arnés se usa para sintetizar una
proteína correspondiente a través del
proceso de traducción veamos un ejemplo
rápido nuestra cadena corta de adn aquí
se utilizará para generar una cadena de
adn recuerden que hace en pareja con
bote y cs en pareja con g a continuación
nuestro arnés se utiliza para generar
proteínas a través de la traducción
recuerden que durante este proceso los
nucleótidos de arn se leen en grupos de
tres llamados codón es para generar los
aminoácidos correspondientes en términos
muy generales decimos que las mutaciones
tienen el efecto de hacer que esta
proteína sintetizada no salga del todo
bien veamos rápidamente la enfermedad de
células falciformes que es un ejemplo de
una enfermedad causada por
una mutación genética quizás recuerden
que hay una proteína de los glóbulos
rojos llamada hemoglobina que también
podemos llamar hb la hemoglobina es una
proteína que coordina los iones de
hierro para retener las moléculas de
oxígeno y transportarlas por todo el
cuerpo la mutación que causa la
enfermedad de células falciformes
produce una forma mutada de hemoglobina
llamada hbs donde la s indica falciforme
por su nombre en inglés la diferencia
entre la hemoglobina normal y la hbs es
que a un residuo de aminoácido glutamato
se reemplaza con un residuo de
aminoácido balín a este pequeño cambio
hace que todas estas proteínas hbs
mutadas se agrupen en un glóbulo rojo lo
que hace que sea muy difícil para ese
glóbulo rojo transportar oxígeno de
manera efectiva por cierto recuerden que
los glóbulos rojos se generan
inicialmente a partir de células madre
hematopoyéticas a través de un proceso
llamado hematopoyesis donde se
encuentran las mutaciones y como surgen
en primer lugar veamos un par de
posibles errores diferentes que podrían
conducir a una proteína producida
incorrecta
primero veremos qué sucede si una célula
comete un error durante la traducción
seguiremos con nuestro ejemplo anterior
de la enfermedad de células falciformes
digamos que tenemos esta muestra de adn
con tres nucleótidos del gen que
codifica la hemoglobina este adn se
transcribe para formar la secuencia de
arn complementaria g a g sg a g
normalmente correspondería a un residuo
de glutamato durante la traducción pero
un error durante la traducción podría
ocasionar que se traduzca un residuo de
valina para producir la hemoglobina
multada asociada con la enfermedad de
células falciformes pero tengamos en
cuenta que si ocurre una mutación
durante la traducción la célula sólo
producirá una hemoglobina mutada o hbs
por cada error como las células producen
toneladas y toneladas de hemoglobina una
sola proteína mutada podría no tener un
efecto tan grande en la célula entonces
podemos decir que los errores durante la
traducción probablemente no causen
mutaciones como la asociada con
enfermedades células falciformes a
continuación veremos los errores durante
la transcripción nueva
tenemos nuestra pieza de adn etc que
normalmente produciría gh en el arn pero
tal vez ocurra un error que conduzca a
la transcripción de un gen que luego
codificar y álava lina asociada con la
hemoglobina mutado si ocurriera este
error la célula sólo produciría unas
pocas hemoglobinas mutadas por cada
error ya que una cadena individual de
arn mensajero solo se traducirá a un par
de veces antes de degradarse entonces
podemos decir que los errores durante la
transcripción probablemente no causen
mutaciones como la asociada con la
enfermedad de células falciformes
finalmente veremos los errores en la
cadena de adn si nuestros etc en el adn
se convierte erróneamente en un se hace
entonces nuestro arnés correspondiente
de la transcripción cambiará y
finalmente se producirá un havalina en
lugar de un ácido glutámico ahora dado
que el adn de una célula almacena toda
su información genética ese error
conduciría a la mutación de todas las
futuras hemoglobinas producidas a partir
de ese gen mutado entonces en general
podemos
decir que las mutaciones serán el
resultado de cambios en el adn de una
célula y no del rn o la proteína
entonces de dónde vienen estos tipos de
mutaciones hay dos formas en que una
persona puede tener una mutación
genética el primero es que lo heredé de
sus padres recuerden que el adn se
transmite de padres a hijos por lo que
si tenemos un padre con el gen mutado
aquí entonces hay una buena posibilidad
de que al menos uno de los hijos heredé
ese gen mutado de la misma manera que el
niño podría heredar cualquier parte del
adn del padre la otra posibilidad es que
la mutación se produzca espontáneamente
que es cuando una persona de repente
sufre una mutación en su adn sin que sus
padres hayan tenido la misma mutación
las mutaciones espontáneas pueden
provenir de muchas fuentes diferentes
algunos ejemplos son errores de
replicación del adn factores ambientales
como ciertos venenos también es posible
que las mutaciones genéticas puedan
aparecer completamente al azar que
aprendimos primero aprendimos que las
mutaciones se originan al nivel de adn y
no al nivel de aire
o de la proteína los efectos de la
mutación como el ejemplo que vimos de la
enfermedad de células falciformes se
relacionan con problemas con las
proteínas que finalmente son expresadas
por el adn mutado ahora como todas las
reglas hay un par de excepciones a esta
pero podemos decir que los efectos de
una mutación generalmente se encuentran
a nivel de la proteína finalmente
aprendimos que las mutaciones se heredan
de uno de los padres o se presentan de
manera totalmente espontánea